so as we get into the middle of the week
this week
we are now really just five weeks from
the start of the first early ballots and
absentee ballots in various states
so i want to have sort of like a very
sober conversation with you
so that we don't all end up surprised
and devastated on november 4th
if donald trump wins we would obviously
still be devastated
but i don't want us to be surprised
despite
all of the polling that we've been
looking at these great polls for joe
biden
in states nationally etc and we'll look
at some of them later
donald trump can still win re-election
here when you look at the historical
precedent
it looks really bad for trump when you
look at being a hundred days out in past
elections
no incumbent has been re-elected with
this level of disapproval
combined with the level of chaos in our
country and in our economy like it looks
historically disastrous for donald trump
trump can't get past 40 approval
two-thirds of the country thinks
coronavirus is getting
worse unemployment is at 11 trump is
underwater in just about every
battleground state trump is mishandling
the three most important issues to
voters today voters
say the most important issues are
coronavirus economy and race relations
and they prefer biden over trump to
different degrees on those three issues
and yet trump can win now
of course we all know there could be a
so-called october surprise and a lot of
the questions i get about how trump
could win are
what kind of october surprise could turn
it around
okay we get a cure and vaccine and trump
takes credit for it and some people fall
for it
maybe trump lies about coronavirus
numbers to justify reopening the economy
and the economy improves even if
temporarily and trump gets credit takes
credit
okay you know trump cures cancer or
something like that
trump goes to war either with another
country or with law enforcement
uh in portland or or chicago as we are
seeing but the thing is we don't
actually even need
a so-called october surprise for donald
trump to win
what can happen has a lot to do with us
and a lot to do with donald trump so on
their side
continued anger at the way trump has
been treated trump has
argued he's the victim he's just treated
so terribly
and some people uh will fall for it and
they could actually say
i'm going to turn out because trump has
been treated so unfairly
only in some of those close key states
and trump could eke this out i'm talking
places like
north carolina pennsylvania florida
places where there's certainly a lead
for biden right now but not necessarily
an overwhelming one
then add to that that the polling could
be slightly too favorable to joe biden
so this is not the polls are wrong
but imagine that the margin of error
which is there for a reason
skews towards donald trump so when biden
is plus four
he's really plus one right now so if
biden's really plus one
you don't need that much for it to be a
trump win by a small margin like we saw
in a bunch of states in 2016. when biden
is plus three right now maybe that's
really a tie
and that could push this even closer and
then the left could do self-inflicted
damage to itself
i talked yesterday about you know let's
postpone some of the policy
disagreements that don't make a
difference right now
until after the election let's focus on
winning as an example i mentioned the
debate between medicare for all
and a public option important debate
significant debate
so important to so many people's lives
but in the next three months it doesn't
do anything for us
biden is not in favor of medicare for
all most senate democrats aren't in
favor of it
and with trump we're not getting either
medicare for all nor the public option
so
what's the point of debating that for
the next three months when the focus
should be get out the vote
the most important thing we can do is
run
as if we're three points behind i'm
sorry run as if we're
10 points behind but vote as if
our vote could decide the states in
which we are voting i know my vote's not
going to decide massachusetts
but i'm operating in the mindset of my
vote is as important as it would be
i'm taking it as seriously as i would
if massachusetts could go one vote to
trump
or by one vote to joe biden if we all
actually do this
we could end up with a historic rebuke
of the republican party
not just the white house but also the
senate if we don't
the devastation on november 4th is going
to be overwhelming
vote early vote absentee if you can i've
already requested my absentee ballot
consider the betting websites which
generally
tend to give joe biden about a 60 chance
of winning right now remember
hillary on many websites had a 70
percent chance in 2016
and she lost so joe biden having 60
means
trump has 40 percent those aren't great
odds for anybody to decide
to stay home if when i see those numbers
i don't say i'll sit back and be an
observer here no
i'll be a participant so the message is
trump can win
trump can win trump can win no
complacency
no smugness or satisfaction from the
polling data
the polling data is a signal that tells
us we have an opportunity
that's the way i see it north carolina
looks like it's biden plus seven i'll
talk about that later
that means biden has an opportunity in
north carolina that's the way we read
the polling until election day that's
all the polling tells us which is why
this has to be the message
until november 3rd let me know your
thoughts on twitter
at deepakman we will take a very short
break and be right back
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number
in your web browser on the phone you can
create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman